YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW THIS -- ONE
OF AMERICA'S SAFEST CITIES.
NOW STRUGGLING TO CONTROL CRIME
AND REDUCE MURDERS.
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD THAT EVEN IN
DEEP BLUE OREGON, THE GOVERNOR'S
MANSION IS NOW IN PLAY FOR
REPUBLICANS.
IT IS SEEN AS A TOSS-UP RACE.
JOINING US TO EXPLAIN MORE,
CHRISTINE, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
WE TALK ALL THE TIME OF THE
PEOPLE STEPPING UP.
IT'S SURPRISING TO ME.
IT'S GREAT THAT IT'S IN PLAY BUT
YOUR STATE HAS JUST BEEN
SUFFERING SO MUCH, WHAT IS YOUR
MESSAGE TO THE PEOPLE OF OREGON
THAT SEEMS TO BE CHANGING THIS
RACE?
>> OREGONIANS ARE DEMANDING
BETTER FROM THEIR LEADERS.
WHAT WE ARE EXPERIENCING HAS
BEEN A DECADE OF DECLINE UNDER
EXTREME SINGLE PARTY LEADERSHIP
AND WE ARE FEELING IT.
ESPECIALLY IN PORTLAND WHEN THEY
ARE LESS SAFE TODAY.
WE ARE SEEING MOM-AND-POP SHOPS
CLOSE.
SEE NATIONAL CHAINS EXIT OUR
BEAUTIFUL CITY.
INSTEAD WE ARE LEAVING OUR CITY
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE ABUSING HARD
DRUGS WHICH ARE NOW LEGAL IN HER
ESTATE, WHO IN FACT ARE FORMING
ENCAMPMENTS, THAT ARE REFUSING
TO LEAVE PUBLIC SPACES.
OUR CITY NEEDS CHANGE.
OUR STATE NEEDS NEW LEADERSHIP
AND THAT'S WHAT OREGONIANS
RESPONDING TO.
>> Tammy: WE SAW IN DEEP BLUE
SAN FRANCISCO THAT FAMILIES ARE
PARENTS.
PARENTS ARE PARENTS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
STEP ON SYRINGES AND HUMAN WHEN
THEY TAKE THEIR KIDS TO A PARK.
AS A REPUBLICAN, IS THERE A
DIFFICULTY AND A WILLINGNESS TO
HEAR THE MESSAGE?
WHAT KIND OF FEEDBACK ARE YOU
GETTING FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS?
>> PORT LANDERS THEMSELVES ARE
ASKING FOR LEADERS THAT ARE
WILLING TO STAND UP FOR THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE.
THEY WANT TO BE SAFE IN THEIR
OWN YARDS.
THEY WANT TO BE SAFE WHEN THEIR
KIDS WALK TO SCHOOL.
THIS IS NOT PARTISAN.
TO YOUR POINT, THIS IS ENTIRELY
ABOUT COMMUNITY SAFETY AND A
QUALITY OF LIFE THAT PORTLANDERS
SHOULD DEMAND AND EXPECT FROM
THEIR EARLY YEARS.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING IT FROM
THEIR LEADERS
RIGHT NOW
AND
THAT'S
WHY MY
ROAD MAP FOR
OREGON'S
FUTURE MAKES
PUBLIC
SAFETY
AND
COMMUNITY SAFETY
ACROSS
OUR
STATE A
CENTRAL
FOCUS OF MY EFFORTS AND
YOU CAN
FIND
MORE INFORMATION
AT
CHRISTINEFOR
OREGON
.COM
>> Tammy: GOOD
LUCK TO
YOU AND
GOOD LUCK TO THE PEOPLE OF
OREGON.
THIS IS ABOUT THE QUALITY OF